okay why don't we go ahead and get
started welcome everyone
so he's good to see a decent turnout in
between terms and we've actually had a
number of these and I've already
apologized to the fellows are the ones
that I'm gonna have to miss due to some
travel commitments but anyways today is
Julian Eggers doctoral symposium which
Polly as most of you know is kind of the
first step towards the dissertation and
in terms of giving a background talk and
of preparing for the research that you
are thinking about doing and then that's
followed by the eventually the proposal
defense and then at the end the defense
of the dissertation anyways a little bit
about Julian he received a bachelor's
degree in bioinformatics with a minor in
computer science from University of
Nebraska Omaha and has worked a few jobs
in between coming here as a
bioinformatics programmer at the Omaha
genrih Doorly Zoo genetics department
looking at evolutionary genomics of
species from Madagascar also spent some
time as a bioinformatics software
engineer for thermo Fisher and coming
here has developed a research interest
in the study of genomics using RNA seek
with an emphasis on alternative splicing
and cellular differentiation and disease
so he will present this symposium today
all right thank you Bill and thank you
everybody for coming to my symposium so
much symposium is differential splicing
analysis with RNA sequencing current
applications approaches and limitations
this is a brief overview about what my
talk will entail I'm just going to give
a brief background on alternative and
differential splicing what it is and
then I'm going to do basically a top
level overview and comparison of the
different methods used for differential
splicing and some
strengths and weaknesses and then also
go into some limitations with the
current methods and also some open areas
for studying differential splicing with
RNA sequencing and then after that I'll
leave it open for questions so starting
out with the central dogma biology I was
a term coined by Francis Crick and I can
58 to basically describe the process in
which the DNA for particulars een can't
be made into an actual protein product
so the central dogma States of course a
protein
you know proteins being the key
component of cells we're gonna keep
building muscle cells the central dogma
states that DNA is first transcribed in
RNA and then RNA is I'm translated in a
protein so why do we have this
intermediate step well first off so
transcription actually occurs within the
nucleus of the cell which is where DNA
is contained in a tightly tightly packed
fashion when after transcription occurs
the translation process up from RNA
actually happens after the RNA is then
taken out from the nucleus and this
happens to ensure that the DNA that we
need to stay protected and prevent from
any sort of DNA DNA damage can stay
protected within the nucleus and have
any sort of you know any sort of
machinery for the transcription
translation or the translation process
of the RNA can all happen outside the
cell and the DNA could be protected from
any of this this also happens though for
an efficiency purpose and a one key to
Southern regulation is not just what
genes are expressed to make what
proteins but also how much of that gene
is expressed to make a certain amount of
proteins and so this by doing this we
have improved efficiency where we can
make multiple RNA templates from a
single gene and then from there we can
make multiple protein products from that
same gene so if you look at this a
little bit closer what actually is going
on but the subtle dogma doesn't show is
that when a gene is transcribed we
actually first have a pre mRNA products
and then this protein complex and as the
spliceosome comes in and it recognizes
these different sites in our premium
product known as exons and introns and
then splices these sized sites out
taking the exon sequences
and forming them together to produce a
full mrna removing the intron sequence
away and then this final mRNA product is
what's used to make the actual protein
looking at this a little bit closer of
what's actually going on here
essentially what we have is we have our
pre mRNA sequence you know from our RNA
which was transcribed from our DNA where
we have all the same bases except for
all of our finding does not replace with
yourselves and the splice of some
protein complex is able to go by and
recognize what are known as splice sites
and it can recognize which sequences
what sequence or regions of sequence
should we use to actually include in our
final memory and product and which other
sequences are introns opening used to
actually remove and not included in our
final mRNA products even more so than
this not only do we have certain
segments that we're going to use for a
final mRNA product we that we can
actually pick and choose which segments
that were going to include in our M&A
product and from there we can actually
produce multiple unique transcripts from
the single gene and so this happens all
the time in fact for multi exon human
genes over 90 percent of those type of
genes actually undergo alternate
splicing and the endgame being here is
not only do we have multiple transcripts
so we can also potentially produce
multiple proteins each with their own
unique possibly different functions or
antagonistic functionality so there's
different ways on which we can actually
do this so in terms of splicing we could
just include you know like if we look at
individual regions of alternate splice
transcripts we can include constituent
of exons and use albeit songs or what
you do is we could use what's called a
cassette exon or more simply put exon
skipping work and actually just you know
either include or exclude this exon to
produce two different transcripts pace
on you know include Renick salinas exon
we gossiped to other things where we
could have alternative splice sites
where we can actually incorporate
different regions of the exons that with
news we can you know have that know for
this case this five prime splice site we
can or include or exclude this
particular region of the exon
and then concatenate it with this next
like Exxon or concatenate this exon from
this and use you know different regions
of this exon
we can even some cases we can also do
what's called intron attention we're
actually continue to include the
intronic region or these will be some of
intronic region or what to do several a
little bit more complicated where we had
mutual exclusivity where we might
include one or the other exon so a few
sin different examples of this for
instance there's what's known as tissue
specific alternative splicing where we
might have the same same gene expressed
into tissue types but we might have only
one of the alternative splice
transcripts expressive one tissue type
and that same one from this place
transcript isn't expressed in other
tissue type and then the resulting
proteins on these two in these two
tissues are completely different and
then they'll have different no different
functional domains of that protein which
can then interfere in create tissue
specific rewiring of protein
interactions in the disease case we can
also have what's known as a baron
splicing or miss splicing essentially so
like a good example of this is where we
might have a mutation on one of our
exons which disrupts the spikes of some
machinery and that leads to an
inappropriate excellent skipping event
leading to a potential oncogene so
differential splicing this is a little
bit different than alternative splicing
and so first off when i'm talking about
here
where most of us are least familiar with
differential gene expression where we're
looking for a significant change in
expression of the single gene between
two different groups and so when we look
at gene expression
we're actually what we're doing is we're
quantity were quantifying the total mRNA
that's transcribed from a single gene so
we might not know a single gene X and we
want to see what's the change in
expression between you know maybe of a
cancer and a non cancer patient or
cancer patients or the non cancer
patients base when I just explained
about its heard of splicing it's not
that we just have one single mRNA we
actually have multiple multiple mRNAs
from alternative splicing so if in a
multiple p.m. RNA is that alternative
splice and so actually what we're
looking at when we're looking at gene
expression we're not just looking at the
expression of one transcript we're
looking at the total expression of all
isoforms from all parts which splice
transcripts so we can see here when we
comparing these two groups of the gene
expression level this is actually a
summation of the in all the different
isoforms that make up that gene and so
looking at this all together here's
another example where we have a single
gene we have 200 term
spliced transcripts and if we look at
the total expression we have a slight
change we have a down regulation in our
cancer case but we don't actually have
necessarily have a significant change of
differential expression what we do have
is a significant change in our different
isoforms expression and then even more
so than that we have what's known as
differential isoform usage where it's
not just the total the total change and
expression of the difference of forms
it's the change in the relative usage of
these isoforms expression to the total
expression of the gene and so that's
what I'm gonna be talking about going
forward here is what differential
splicing is so differential explain is a
difference in the expression of all
eternally spliced transcripts relative
to the total expression of the gene
between two or more conditions so again
looking at this case we have two
isoforms we might have the same
expression at the gene level but what we
do have is a significant change in the
proportion of expression between
isoforms that make up that gene and just
to avoid confusion going further there's
a lot of synonyms when it comes to
differential splicing I'll mostly be
referring to it as different to splicing
you've already heard me at this case in
a referred to as differential isoform
usage isoforms switching differential
transcript prescription etc and then
going back to a few examples of actual
differential splicing biology disease
you know if you look at our tissue
example again it's not so much that we
might just have you know one transcript
expressive one tissue and the other
change and another transcript only
expressing other tissue what we'll
probably have is actually with both
transcripts are actually expressed and
both tissues but what we have is a
differential usage or differential
relative usage of those where one
transcript is completely expressed a lot
more than the other transcript the one
tissues versus the other tissue and then
going back to another cancer case
there's a really well studied case of
this for the VCL x gene where the two
alternates place transcripts produce
proteins with antagonistic
functionalities for one is pro apoptotic
and the other one is anti-apoptotic
and as you can imagine in the cancer
cases this anti-apoptotic
has a much more dominant expression than
Manami
a pop tonic version and probably the
most most significant cases adentro
spicing that contributes to biology is
in cellular differentiation a particular
seller differentiation program known as
epithelial to the second all transition
is basically developmental program where
we have these these tightly compact
surface barrier cells that are in mobile
and they undergo differentiation program
where they slowly change into the these
been Seconal cells that have a lot more
maturity and a lot more or more loosely
organized together and how this
transition occurs is well it's driven by
a distinct change in overall gene
expression so hundreds of genes have are
either down regulated or up regulated so
these cells can track these epithelial
cells can then differentiate these
economica cells more so than that though
we also have this piece trained is
further driven by expression of splicing
events where we have expression of book
you know we might have alternative
splice transcripts from the same gene
that are both expressing both so types
but we have an increase of certain
splicing variants and in certain one
cell type in a decrease and this change
occurs that helped drive forward this
change in differentiation and so this is
really a good way I think to kind of put
together what differential splicing is
and how it kind of contributes to
overall gene expression where you know
we have our change in gene expression
profile so looking at this is a plot
showing differential expression where we
have our epithelial cells on the second
cells we can see which genes are
differentially splice all the black dots
are or seeping out differently expressed
all the black dots represent
differentially expressed genes and then
all the dark gray representative
differently spliced genes or genes that
are both differently spliced and
differentially expressed so we can see
all of our differently and expressed
genes we also see in the middle here
these genes aren't the ones under dark
gray aren't meant necessarily
differentially expressed but the
difference of the splice and we also
have cases where this dark gray on the
outside is kind of takes a boat cases
where it's both difference they express
in both differently splice and so we can
kind of look at look at as where the
differential expression kind of Tunes
this differentiation program and then
this the difficult splicing of these
gene
sort of fine-tunes this program so it
kind of further drives the phenotype of
these two cells so how can we go about
studying differential splicing well one
way we can do this is by utilizing RNA
sequencing and so the goal of RNA
sequencing is to measure the dam
the dynamic transcriptome of cells
basically and so I stay dynamic in the
sense of the transcriptome it's not only
does it represent all the RNA but the
transcriptome itself is dynamic and that
we have different expression of that RNA
or different amounts of that RNA so when
we look at RNA sequencing and we look at
the transcriptome we're starting to trip
them both in a qualitative fashion where
we're looking at the actual RNA
sequences that are present within AMP
we're looking at the alternative splice
transcripts we're also looking at the
expression of those of that RNA and
expression of those ultralights
transcripts just a really brief overview
and basic workflow of how RNA sequencing
works essentially what we do is if we
want to look at the transcript tones
between two different samples or two
different groups for instance two
different cell types what we'll do is
we'll isolate all the mRNA from both
those cell types did the nature of the
sequencing will actually create CD and
many fragments just because it's more
stable than RNA and then we'll fragment
all that cDNA enough to kind of
different sizes with different links and
what we'll do is we'll sequence all
these cDNA fragments of a massively
parallel fashion producing hundreds of
millions of these short reads so
basically our entire transcriptome from
these from each one of these cells is
contained in the big comic blob
you know globular mass of hundreds of
millions of short reads that make up or
transcriptome so what do we do from
there we got to piece it all back
together so here over reads where all of
our transcriptome is and basically you
have to sort of make out everything
that's there and kind of piece it all
back together so how we do that we can
align it to a reference genome which is
a sequential representation of our
genome we could and look align these
sequences identify where they're at but
we can also utilize what's known as
transcriptome annotations and so these
transcriptome annotations basically
represent our destructors of our genes
and the sense of transcripts in the
sense of exons where for instance this
is a single gene and these are you know
two alternative splice transcripts from
that
and these represent the positions of the
exons relative to the actual reference
genome and then so when we align our
reads down down onto our genome we can
actually make out the structures and
then more importantly we can also
quantify the different transcripts that
we have here but from our Nisa
concerning utilizing the annotations
aligned to the reference genome and a
few things still kind of notice right
away and I'll talk about this more as we
go is that certain reads first alerts
first up is that when we line to the
genome the genome represents where our
genes would be before splicing so but
you have to remember when we isolated
this mRNA this is actually from fully
mature process mrna post splicing so
when we go back to the line in a
splicing where a whiner will actually
split the reads at where the splice
junctions work and so based on if we
have unique splice junctions between the
transcripts have been actually
disambiguate which reads belong to its
transcript you'll see right away we also
have issues where we have certain reads
that if they align the same position
where that are shared between where
Nexon is shared between two or more
transcripts we had this ambiguous case
where we're not really sure which is
transcript of origin for these
individual reads another thing to keep
in mind is these transcriptome
annotations themselves depending what
organism we're studying is some a lot of
times these transcriptome annotations
are active fairly incomplete even for
really well study of organisms like
humans and mice we still have incomplete
annotations for certain genes and even
more so than that we might also have
cases of aberrant splicing where we
might have some sort of novel splice
site occur that isn't contained within
our transcriptome annotations so when it
comes to actually analyzing differential
splicing there's actually different
methods we can take and so there's sort
of these three general methods and even
though biologically we might be looking
at the same thing we can actually go in
and look at it a different way and from
there we can actually ask different
questions about our data so what I'm
gonna do this isn't meant to be a huge
laundry list about the kinetics but I'm
just one of you that kind of described
the different approaches that use take
and kind of explain how they're
different and how they're actually able
to ask different questions and in doing
so many use basically a use case
of an example piece of software and
these three software are pretty much the
you know the most utilized software for
each one of these approaches so the
first one I'm gonna talk about is what's
known as the isoform resolution approach
and this is probably the most intuitive
approach for looking at difference of
splicing baseboard on how I explained
alternative splicing worse so basically
what we're doing is when I look for the
differences in the complete isoform
proportions or the expression of those
isoforms between different samples and
so the software and focus here is the
software known as cuffdiff
and the experiment approach that
cuffdiff captive takes is that it tries
to assemble all full-length isoforms
from our data estimate the expression of
all the transcripts and then test for
relative differences between two or more
samples between two or more samples so
cuff dip is actually part of the nars
RNA sex week called tuxedo where this
suite is basically used for assembling
quantifying and testing different genes
and transcripts for the differential
expression and differential splicing the
module of cufflinks is actually does the
assembly and the expression estimation
and then cut if is what actually does
the testing for differential expression
to function splicing and so what
cufflinks does it utilizes all varèse
for our reference genome it also has the
optional it also has the option of
utilizing transcriptome annotations but
it's not required and what it tries to
do it is it tries to find all these
mutual competitor all these mutually
compatible fragments to try to
disambiguate different transcripts from
the data and so it does this by finding
the minimal amount of transcripts that
best explains the aligned reads it uses
listeners awaited bipartite graph and
then it tries to assemble the
transcripts based on the data and then
has to use on sort of an estimation
approach to actually figure out the
actual estimate the actual expression
over individual transcripts so it has to
model this you can see a lot right away
we have the same issue that I talked
about earlier where we have certain
splice junctions that he meets and
certain transcripts but if we have
reasons align to ambiguous regions we're
not able to actually identify the
transcript of origin after a quantifying
or after identifying assembling all of
our transcripts and estimating the
abundance of all those change
so we can then do the actual different
splicing test so this is what cuffdiff
comes in it looks for a change on
isoform abundance using a one-sided
t-test of a distance metric this
distance metrics known as the Jensen
Jensen shannon divergence distance
metric where we can test basically use a
distance metric to test the difference
in the relative abundance of isoforms
between two or more samples so as to
form resolution models so what are they
good for and what you know why are they
beneficial well you know the most
obvious reason is that we actually can
resolve and look at full-length isoforms
which is kind of the intuitive thing
that we want to do so we could you know
in this case we could look for isoforms
that went under this you know underwent
significant differential splicing or
significant isoforms switching we could
identify potential biomarkers if you
know we find a gene that had significant
significant isoforms switching and also
show that a significant stratification
for instance like in a survival analysis
we also have the ability where we can
actually look at the full that look at
predictions about the proteins that
those different isoforms actually encode
so if we have differential splicing for
particular isoform
we can look at what domains were
affected by the differential splicing
and what how that actually interferes
with things on the network level we're
at a protein level and how that might
interfere with protein networks but
again there's a sort of this limitation
that we have with these isoform
resolution models where we have this
ambiguity with you know region one in
the same positions so I said formalize
resolution models although they're nice
and we produced certain things there's a
lot of complexity that comes with it so
there's kind of different approaches we
can take to try to resolve from this
complexity that we have we trying to
actually assemble full-length
transcripts and try to estimate their
expression what we can do is a more
isolated approach we're known as an exon
uses approach where we try to actually
look at differences in exon specific
expression so exon uses approach in this
specific piece of software called Dex
seek its experimental approach is to
actually focus on differential exon
usage and like I mentioned before it
tries to avoid that complexity that we
have with China actually resolved full
ranked transcripts and trying to
estimate that expression by actually
narrowing it down and look at the
individual exons
for all the different early spice
transcripts so it it equates to a
virtual splicing with basically
differential exon usage or differential
expression of the exon level so how this
works the epsilon usage bottle by Dec
seat it utilizes the transcriptome
annotations provided by the user and
what it does is essentially flattens all
that all of our exon models into sort of
like this single unit and then any sort
of overlap that we might have with
overlapping exons and then splits it
into non-overlapping exonic bins it then
quantifies those exotic bins just like
you would quantify maybe like a single
gene separately for each individual
brand based on our read densities and
then when we go to test for them for the
splicing what it does is it uses a job
well similar to actually differential
expression approach it uses a
differential uses a generalized linear
model to test for differential exon
usage or a differential expression at
the exon level only and this time our
generalized linear model now accounts
for the total expression of all the
exons within the gene and then we can
look for basically significant
differential expression of this exon and
look first you know significant axon to
underwent differential splicing based on
like a you know an FDR cutoff and we
could how to utilize this in a different
way although we didn't resolve our you
know our full-length transcripts we can
still we might actually have a more
accurate approach because we didn't have
to do that abundance estimation at the
transcript level where we can actually
just utilize you know utilize them for
the the results at the gene level where
we can say okay we know that this gene
underwent some form a differential
splicing and we could therefore use that
gene as potential biomarker or we could
even just use that exon in that
differentially spliced exon could
actually use you know it's a particular
biomarker so a splicing of that approach
kkona extends upon that exon level
approach where again we want to avoid
that complexity of trying to resolve
transcripts but rather than just looking
at the individual exons we basically
want to try to add some sort of
biological relevant information to it
where we're gonna actually look at
different splicing events that could
actually have so as the software I'm
looking at is the software called our
Maps where it focuses on localized
splicing events so through all of our
data it's going to look for these
different kind of
splicing patterns it's gonna equate
differential splicing with basically a
differential inclusion of these
different events for instance whether or
not if do we have this context on though
do we not have to skip that song and
like I said I get much before it extends
upon this exon base approach by adding
biologically relevant information so how
it does this so again we're looking at
our transcriptome annotations what it's
going to do it's going to identify
different splicing event patterns that
are found between all of our transcripts
so this case we have four transcripts
and we have an exon skipping event where
three three of our transcripts include
the exon and another transcript doesn't
include an exon what we're gonna do is
we're gonna flatten those structures
down into its own unit and now we can
actually look at the inclusion or
exclusion and basically just you know
two cases just the inclusion of the
inclusion of the exon exclusion exon and
we can quantify no longer do we have to
quantify using all these individual
transcripts everything can be quantified
right here on this level and we quantify
that with using what's known as percent
spliced in was essentially of the total
expression of these two cases what's the
percentage of the transcript being
expressed that not will not necessary
the transcript but what's being
expressed on the exit for the exon
inclusion versus the exon skipping so we
have the total expression of these guys
and then like for instance maybe point
seven of the total expression
maybe three-fourths of expression is
coming from the exon inclusion of that
when it comes to actually testing for
different splice a little difference
with splicing what we'll do is we'll
determine the change in inclusion
between two or more samples and then use
the likelihood ratio test to determine
the p-value for a change of percent
splice in exceeding some sort of the
fine threshold for instance we could
look for significant change in splicing
that's greater than maybe 5 percent or
10 percent and so what this might look
at so we kind of localized her view
we're looking at a single gene across to
sing you know for two samples with three
replicates for each sample and we're
testing the inclusion exclusion up or
exclusion of this particular splicing
bag
and we can see here between these two
samples we have a change of percent
splice in about 10% where low - the
overall expression this one has a much
in this sample we have a much lesser
extent of contribution to the this
included Mex on that in the other sample
so how are these useful we can use these
a lot of different ways they're really
nice they might be a little more
accurate in the sense that we're not
looking at full transcript complexity
but then we can actually use these
splicing events for you know again four
particular biomarkers for instance we
could look at different splicing events
across different cancer types and maybe
identify significant biomarkers in the
form of splicing events so whatever they
want to get into is some of the
limitations and then open areas for
differential splicing analysis and so
one of the first kind of gap an open
area for different splicing is what's
known as overlapping transcriptome
features so what do I mean by
overlapping transcriptome features so
basically there are features we can look
at this in the sense of our annotations
futures that basically overlap in either
their sum or partial manner and again
these features were really looking at is
all these individual exons but kind of
recall this transcript on future
hierarchy where we can have genes you
know for instance this is a single gene
that can have multiple transcripts and
then all these possible transcripts are
made up of individual exons so for the
most part we're looking when I say
overlapping transcriptome feature we'll
be just looking at these individual
exons relative to their position along
the genome so overlapping genes so keep
in mind that DNA is double-stranded so
we can actually code for proteins using
both strands of DNA so this leads to the
potential where we might have
overlapping genes filling in opposite
strands that are actually now utilizing
kind of the same regions of the genome
for the same but the necks off but on
the opposite strands however we also
have cases where we can have overlapping
genes going on the same strand where two
different genes can actually on the same
strand utilize some of the same as exon
some in two different genes and this
actually happens quite a bit so this is
a study looking at you know looking at a
set of annotations these gencode version
19 right
to see what was the extent of
overlapping at the gene level and one
thing to kind of keep in mind is that
this is including only the coding
regions so it pulls out only the protein
coding exon regions from all the genes
and looks at the degree above the lab
across every chromosome so we can see we
have a much greater amount of overlap on
the opposite strand versus the same
strand for opposite strand we have
anywhere between 10 to 30% of our genes
are overlapping on a single chromosome
and even though it's not as much was
still the significant amount of
overlapping genes that are found on the
same strand so in they were between 5 to
50 percent of genes on chromosomes are
overlapping on the same strand this is
just showing the distribution based on
how much of the exon protein coding
regions auburgine overlap and what's the
degree of genes that actually had this
much overlap to both same strand and
opposite strand overlapping genes and
then keep in mind like I talked about
earlier we can also have overlapping
features just within genes so due to
alternative splicing where a single gene
could have multiple transcripts sharing
all or some of certain exons for those
transcripts and now if we include
overlapping exons from alternative
splice transcripts and not just
overlapping genes we're gonna see that
we have upward expecially in humans we
have upwards of hundreds of thousands of
exons that are actually going to be
overlapping so this proof presents a lot
of issues for analyzing differential
splicing so either way whether they're
you know alternative splice genes
sheireen exons or they're overlapping
genes on the same adopts it's Tran they
present problems so how do we handle
this so first off with overlapping
features on the opposite strand luckily
there is something we can do now is what
we can use what's known as strain
specific library prep where there's a
lot of ways to do this but essentially
what we're doing is we're able to
basically tag our reads and to saying
what
whoops strand there were actually
sequence from so in the case of what we
do have overlapping we can kind of
resolve that ambiguity issue and
actually see okay this is on one strand
you know all these reads had to come
from that strand and all these reads
have to come from another strand so we
have an overlapping case right away even
though they align to the same dénouement
position to like the same exon
structures essentially we can actually
disambiguate
that note which reads belong to her
strand and can come to deal with this
overlapping June issue however we still
have the same strand issue which is kind
of left where we can have overlapping
genes over you know overlapping features
from the same gene or overlapping
features from different genes and they
all present issues to these different
these different approaches for
differential splicing so for the I so
bait I support based approach for
overlapping genes remember we had this
ambiguous issue where we can't assign on
it we can assign ambiguous reads to the
individual transcripts and so kind of
how cufflinks have to do this is it
needs to assign these different reads to
the right you know I so formal or exam
so it uses a maximum likelihood
estimation to try to determine okay
what's the most probable
what's the most probable isoform that
one of these reads could have belonged
to so by doing this we get an estimation
with a certain bit of uncertainty and
now so all of our expression for each
one of our transcripts that we're
looking at is now based on the
probability with the given sense of
uncertainty and it's those uncertain yes
and certainly estimates that are used on
the actual testing for differential
splicing between two conditions so a key
problem of that to keep in mind is that
as we increase the number of transcripts
that we might have and we increase the
amount of exons that are shared or
partially shared the decrease our
certainty and the estimation of the
expression of those different
transcripts so when we go to overlapping
genes this amplifies the issue and the
cufflinks approach to do that so in the
case where we had two overlapping genes
with two different two alternative
splice transcripts for each gene what
coupling says it actually groups all the
overlapping genes into a single group
and then it goes and it estimates the
relative abundance of each transcript
from each gene within that group and
then does the test that way between the
two conditions and this leads to
obviously a lot of issues we have that
and ambiguity issue of aligned reads but
we're also unable to distinguish
splicing at the gene level so for
instance if we detect splicing we don't
actually know what gene was actually
differentially spliced and again like I
mentioned before by doing this we
increase the number of transcripts we
increase the probability of having exons
overlap which decreases our certainty
for our bonus estimation
and we lose power to detect significant
changes in transcript abundance so the
Exxon based approach for overlapping
genes if we recalled approaches for
alternative splice genes where we take
our annotations and we kind of compress
this down into the single structure deck
seat takes maybe one of two approaches
to look at overlapping genes so one way
we can do this is the same thing we did
for alternative splice genes or the
alternative splice transcripts we can
compress all this together now where we
have all the trans or all the exons from
all the transcripts from all the gene
into basically a single unit where all
the overlapping exons are split into
individual exonic bins or what we could
do is a separate test where we actually
just take any overlapping features and
completely remove it for our test so if
you test it this way we'll test the
genes separately but we'll only be doing
on the exons that weren't shared so
we're not gonna be doing any sort of
tests on for instance these exons so
this presents a lot of issues so
obviously we have that issue of lost
exons which like I showed you earlier in
the case of humans we're gonna have
hundreds of thousands of excellence
either overlap that could be lost on
this by this approach again we have just
like the isoparm resolution issue we
have ambiguity at the gene level so we
don't know which genes are actually
undergoing differential splicing if
we're testing them as a single group and
if we do this and I'm not kind of
another issue is we can actually mistake
differential expression for instructions
splicing for instance if we tested this
particular exon and this gene was
actually differentially spliced this
exon there's certain cases where this
exon actually be picked up as
differential exon usage when it's
actually differential or differential
gene expression so the splicing of that
approach for overlapping genes is a
little bit different so we have again we
have our two genes overlapping what
despite with the event base approach
does just like before it goes and
identifies all the different splicing
events from the transcriptome
annotations and then all the events are
annotated subtly for each gene for each
event for each gene and so there's no
regard to overlap and so each test for
each event is going to be done
separately for each gene so we're not
grouping genes together like we did with
some of the other methods the problem
comes though for again the ambiguous
read issue where we might have
in accurate estimations because what our
mats will do is any sort of ambiguous
trees that could go to either gene it's
just gonna count the expression it's
gonna count this read towards the
expression of both genes so that you
know could potentially to you know in
accurate estimations of our actual
percent splice ten which is therefore
lead to inaccurate changes in percent
splice in or inaccurate differential
splicing but the the but based approach
is actually really really is actually a
pretty good approach to take for the
purchase pricing um it's actually
probably the most used method I would
say and again one of the reasons for
this is that avoids that complexity of
trying to resolve transcripts and trying
to estimate different abundance of
transcripts but also other unlike the
exon usage case it actually tries to
incorporate biologically relevant
information and kind of how that why why
it's so good is that we can now compress
all these transcripts into a single unit
and by quantifying this just on the
single unit and all these different
transcripts we can actually increase our
power to actually detect differential
splicing or police differential
inclusion of this event it's very useful
again we can use you know just like a
skipped exon for instance as a
significant biomarker if we want again
like using a survival analysis that's an
example we can just instead of trying to
look at all the transcripts for instance
for this step five a gene we can
actually just look at this exon or not
however the problems that come with the
vet based models are complex alternative
splicing events where event based models
like our mats are actually only looking
at splicing patterns that kind of fall
into one of these five categories and
this is any sort of pattern that we
could have and there's a lot of them
that aren't you know just simple exon
skipping or just a simple different
differentiated splice site or a mutual
exclusive exon it misses any of those
and additionally it also only looks all
the events that it looks at or strictly
binary it's always you know
inclusion or exclusion of the of like a
skipped exon is always you know one site
or the other side for this sex on their
backs on it doesn't it can't handle
anything that might have maybe three or
more possibilities for one particular
splicing with that so the limitation of
that based model is complex is complex
splicing events
and we actually have a lot of this if we
look at you know another study looking
at trying to annotate different splicing
patterns through our annotations we're
gonna see for you know two really well
studied organisms we have almost 20% of
our splicing patterns actually don't
fall into one of these five categories
so what is complex splicing besides just
not falling into one of these well kind
of a few examples there's different ways
we could look at this one could be no
compound events where we're actually
just using multiple simple splicing
events but you know all in sort of one
fashion or we can have you know for
instance an alternative splice site
compounded with a skipping event we
could also have multiple skipped exons
so event based methods usually only are
able to detect you know one exon being
skipped we actually have cases where you
might have like a cluster of excellence
like these skips a really good example
of this is this barred warn gene which
has actually been what actually produces
multiple alternative splice transcripts
where the alternate splice transcripts
are undergo extensive exon cluster
skipping and these different transcripts
have been found to be different to be
spliced in different cancer types and
these different the different proteins
ever actually translated from these
different transcripts all have unique
interactions with the bracha one gene
and breast cancer
so yeah the event base table would be
missing all these two clusters and I
like I kind of match before
non-binary events where it's not just
inclusion or exclusion of one of them we
could have cases like in this example
just camp K 2 G 2 G gene it's a non
Buried case where we can actually use
any combination of the of these groups
of exons right here and looking at K
this is our T qpcr showing the
expression of these different
combinations across different Mouse
tissues where we actually have
preferential expression of these
different you know splicing patterns
across different tissues and if I so
this is my last kind of open area that I
want to talk about which is kind of more
from them kind of falls into an umbrella
case of just trying to improve the
annotation and quantification of
alternative splicing so we can use them
for differential splicing tests and this
particular thing I'm gonna talk about
it's just the idea of you know utilizing
the both both novel and then Sabo
approaches to try to you know better
annotate and better quantify the
different splicing splicing events so we
use them for different splicing to us so
looking again at event and exon based
approaches again the really great
methods they resolve that complexity
issue but there are the thing about them
is that that are highly dependent on the
transcriptome annotations they're very
limited if we're doing this type of test
on you know for instance a particular
organism that doesn't have very complete
transcriptome annotations or in the case
where we have some sort of novel
splicing from you know for instance from
the parent splicing they're limited in
that they can actually detect that so
there's one kind of idea is the use of
alternative splicing graft so sorry
splicing grafts have been around for a
while that as a way to sort of identify
different splicing patterns and
different genomes and one thing we can
do by using or splicing grasses if we
can take our annotations it basically
build a graph representing all of our
variant splicing patterns that that we
could have from all the different
transcripts so we take the annotations
and then build this graph representing
all the possible variants and so we can
use this for instance if we want to
build a abet based method we actually
instead of trying to find all of our
events form annotations we could first
build our graph and then from there
actually try to identify events well
okay how does this help us well we can
also do is we don't can't we can also
not just utilize our annotations but
similar to an isotherm resolution
approach we could also utilize our data
we can use our why utilize our line we
need to also add to our alternative
splicing graph and in this case now
would be able to detect novel splicing
events and then going a step further we
could then possibly annotate and
quantify complex splicing events but
don't fall into one of those five basic
splicing patterns but the typical event
based methods would actually take so
they're all kind of conclude and
summarize just that differential
splicing is an often honored utilized
analysis from RNA sex studies although
it's something I think that is
worthwhile annotating quantifying
alternative splicing is still inherently
difficult you know due to problems that
we have with RNA sack it's a much more
complicated process than just looking at
expression at the gene level there's
multiple approaches all of which have
their different advantages and all of
which are actually asking different
questions that are all could be helpful
in different ways
however limitations still exist with all
these different methods like I mentioned
a few overlapping features and complex
spicing being really good examples of
that and also that I think that using
both novel and ensemble approaches for
finding and testing different digital
spicing may actually improve the
robustness of analysis so with that is I
want to thank again ossu the D my
student faculty and staff all the beasts
of these fellows who are helping me put
together this talk as I was doing this I
definitely wanna take think mice
imposing community who were here today
and also acknowledge my animal training
grant and with that care of my
references you see that's just like a
blah grammatically you sell it the EC so
say that again you said EC seek you were
saying oh no you might have been
referring to the wrong that was just a
citation for that where I got the figure
for nice easy see yeah that's just like
a bioinformatics resource website the
only question is what databases exist
that have strand-specific sequencing
data
oh well that that's just part of the RNA
sequencing so to answer your question
databases that would just be like short
SRA shorts not it well then is it a
technique for library preparation yeah
this is a technique for library
privilege but everyone does it um not
everybody it's it's before a used to
only only be unstrained it but now a
more like modern improvement to RNA
sequencing is that we can just random
prep so if you look at you know if you
get some RNA sequencing data you want to
know
so yeah the data you've looked at is
probably listed as being strange things
probably the data I look that's already
summarized right it's just like one
thing I didn't talk about did not get
too technical it's just like paired-end
reads I didn't know you could have
singled and read your page we'd also
have stranded run stranded
I'll go ahead and ask exhale make a
comment and a question there's some
actually there's a few people in this
room who are almost well who are about
my age we learned in college the central
dogma and it was so much simpler back
then yeah all that others still it still
it yeah it's that's still how it is it's
just we kind of zoom in there's a lot
more well it seemed dead you know
and we didn't know introns and exons
right and so forth but my question is
what are some of the applications of
this I you know it's not an expert in
right you know makes I I understand the
different methods to kind of figure out
how the splicing takes place what are
some of the applications of this that
you would you know use in your
dissertation yeah there's a lot of
different applications you know some of
my interest might be more for you know
just discovery you know trying to look
for you know how splicing might affect
proteins and approaching - names
interactions of proteins one of the
actions example I kind of like is this
this EMT program I talked about this
this differentiation program is actually
pretty strongly theorized to be a big
part of metastasis where these cells
actually these cells would be kind of
with a primary tumor D and it's strongly
believe that the Biblia bility to
metastasize is that the cancer cells
actually hijack this program so I think
you know one way you know how much we
could take with that is maybe trying to
understand exactly how cells are able to
metastasize and how they're able to
hijack this program knowing that
differential splicing kind of plays a
key role in this going further to more
of the clinical sense what I would
actually like to do is make a look at
the verge of splicing and you know
metastasis patients so right now we have
a lot of data of both normal tissue and
primary cancer tissue I'd like to see
pair pair data and do an analysis in
both normal tissue primary tissue and
then metastasis tissue to try to look
for maybe biomarkers on a splicing level
to look for you know patients are likely
to metastasize or
might affect survival or treatment and
things like that just like you know and
again I say something that you don't
like treatment like that's a good way to
look you know I could feel that at units
pressure weekly gene expression has
potential biomarkers for maybe treatment
options or survival looking at different
splicing just kind of another layer that
we might be missing with RNA sequencing
we could actually identify biomarkers of
the splicing level to kind of complement
the decline of gene expression
I was just I'm just wanting to be a
comment on the assemble method they were
speaking up if the advantages and
limitations of actually using existing
annotation with your ensemble method the
limitations of using existing
annotations right um yeah absolutely so
one of the key limitations is that is
kind of it could be biased towards those
so you know if we try to build our graph
you know from those annotations we might
we might have splicing that's not
actually there but we're using those
annotations to sort of build that
structure pretty hands where maybe that
splice ended in the curb but it's being
included even though our reason aligned
to it so maybe a counter approach would
be to build maybe two different options
or you could build it from your
transcriptome annotations but also just
use it completely de novo and do it on
the reads so for instance you know we
might be forcing our graph to maybe
actually include these exons when we
actually don't have that in their data
and we're now building or graph from
that particular epsilon just because it
was in our annotations when maybe it
actually wasn't expressed second even
possible
so how um and this is kind of a looking
forward question how are you you know
we've had a tremendous change in
technology right we've been able to do
in terms of sensitivity and and so if
you think about it from that perspective
of as you're working on your as you work
on you propose on the market rotation
there's gonna be this moving target
about us being able to go after lower
abundant transcripts right about being
able to actually like for example I
think the annotation even our assemblies
will update write longer reads and so
have you thought at all about a way to
try and be dynamic in that perspective
um a little bit I mean I think one
example maybe first off so she was
talking about longer reads better
annotations you know again one that
limitations about this you know I
mentioned with ISIF um resolution models
or any of this is that the reason our
excellence structures so that's what
they and big utilized as reads get
longer that can resolve some of this
complexity issue but right now with the
way the technology is the the long reads
are actually we have a lower depth so
these are confidence and they're much
more error prone so kind of what she's
talking about as that technology gets
better we can do this at a cheap you
know it gets better it's cheaper it's
more available that'll actually improve
our ability to actually look at
difficult I sing in terms of kind of
going forward that's technology a really
big example I can think of is
single-cell RNA sequencing so a single
cell we can actually look at individual
cells and as opposed to just a bulk set
of cells for single cell sequencing
that's already and I'm not a total
expert on single cell sequencing but
that's already difficult as it is just
for the gene expression levels so you
can imagine it's even more difficult if
we actually try to look at a
alternatively spliced expression or a
Tony splice transcript expression but
there are people who are doing that and
I think that's something I would be
really excited for but that has a really
long way to go and so yes doing that
going forward in order to do that though
there'd actually would have to be a
probably a syndicate change in the
approach in certain ways of how we're
actually able to handle of all the noise
a complexity that comes out of single
cell sequencing but yeah absolutely I
think
for this type of analysis and years
going forward as the technology better I
think being able to do this watch we get
better as RNA sequencing gets better and
as we get better more complete
annotations and databases and
orientations in splicing
but you do you see something about like
a whole alternative splicing is
controlled like in different tissue
types oh sorry
okay how alternative splicing is
controlled or is it
well yeah essentially so I can't brought
that example up earlier where we might
have tissue specific differential
splicing where this the expression of
the different transcripts could be
regulated in different ways so for
instance we could have two different
tissues where you know let's say we have
two transcripts both transcripts are
being expressed in both tissues but the
relative usage of those different
transcripts are different so you know
for instance maybe like in brain cells
you know transcript one is expressed it
contributes to eighty percent of the
total gene expression we're in another
tissue it mayn't the only contributes to
maybe 20% of the gene expression does
that does that answer your question
perhaps no it doesn't yeah what actually
causes this oh that's better country um
yeah
so um what actually kind of controls the
expression of the alternative splice
transcripts are like splicing regulator
proteins which are essentially like
transcription factors for alternative
splicing or at least that's how I look
at it so I'm assuming since you're
familiar with that I can explain this
first you might have a transcription
factor that regulates the expression of
the splicing regulatory proteins and
those are splicing regulatory proteins
actually fine to Sisson trans elements
along our sequence that then regulate
eight regulates the expression of the
alternate spliced transcripts so
actually one of the things I would
really like to look at from a network
progeny
correlation of both transcription
factors and splicing regulatory factors
and their correlation with the actual
you know how the quantity of splicing we
have so for instance we could correlate
the total expression of splicing whether
Tory proteins with the splicing and
inclusion of the different 3 splice of
the difference with splice genes that
make sense so yeah so it's that
controlled by those regulatory proteins
could actually are what's going to
control
the degree of spicing that we have in
different issues
no that's something essentially would be
like you know a correlation network by
incorporating most llamas yeah I I said
I'm a genius
I met the expression of the church yeah
I would look at it more as doing like
just a gene correlation that works where
you just yeah where you're doing gene
expression but trying to incorporate you
know maybe both the gene expression for
like for instance with regulatory genes
with some sort of how it depends how we
quantify it but with the splicing so for
instance like percent splicing that I
mentioned how right right
so does this yeah does this regulatory
gene that control spicing does that
expression correlate with the percent
inclusion of maybe I should do you see
people do this type of correlational
analysis I've seen people recently kind
of try it
I think there's I think what would be
interesting is how they're actually
quantifying that so I mentioned you know
if we want to sort of correlate
expression with splicing how do we
actually pull it that whisp licen well
what ways we can do that doctor Danny on
cue he has his exon level correlation
that were his splicing network is based
on like correlations between individual
exons so there's not actually any gene
expression integrated within that it's
just the correlation between different
exons between different genes some other
approaches that what I've seen people do
is maybe they did kind of what I
mentioned where they take the expression
of the splicing regulatory genes and
correlate that with for instance like
the pro maybe percent splicing of
splicing events or maybe the actual ice
upon level expressions that's another
thing I've seen is where they basically
build a network that overlays both gene
expression and then I suppose specific
expression within the gene expression
but yeah I think that's actually
something brilliant I'm pretty
interested in looking
Christon I kind of mentioned this view
before but is there any like mechanistic
like lab studies that have been done
that instead of correlating with like
quantity looking at actual like type of
splicing like the idea that like uh
splicing a specific type of splicing
factor actually is responsible for a
certain certain type of yeah um probably
the best example I actually kind of
showed this when I gave a fellow's talk
a few months ago was they were doing a
splicing event type of analysis and
there's known splicing regulatory genes
and they looked at the the type of
events that were present and then they
did a knockout model where if they
knocked out different splicing events or
excuse me they knocked out the different
regulatory genes they could see which
events sort of dropped on I can't
remember if they actually were able to
see exactly what like if there was
really some reason betwenn what genes
had what events or if it was kind of
just circumstantial but like you know
maybe by knocking out this particular
gene we lost maybe 30% of our exon
skipping events we lost maybe 10% of our
alternative Phi prime splicing events or
so forth so I think yeah I don't think
the people probably looked at that it's
just like how much detail yeah could you
actually see it right inside of Syria is
so-called a splicing machine right right
now which content probably over like
here's our proteins so contrary by all
these porches right right right yeah I
mean like the like the spliceosome
machinery like right right
I'm not I'm not uh proposing any aims or
you know anything like that Bernie
analysis plans I'm just doing an
overview of my the area I'm interested
in and the background and what I
understand to this point of this area so
well
[Applause]